here with alex monk he's a therapist that's got a book trauma and the supernatural On eagle's wings and fly if we got the video i was trying to do a little bit of prop comedy i was going to get some american stereotypes and show up in a cowboy hat and with a donut or something i don't have a gun but uh you know i'm not sure do um is are those your associations you know as a as a londoner yeah i think so yeah yeah the usual stereotypes i think yeah okay your book's fascinating and um you've got kind of an interesting perspective that I imagine cuts a little bit of the grain most places. A lot of the stuff that I'm into that I feel like is kind of inevitable and coming back into clinical practice is sort of controversial or not controversial but maybe poorly understood um could you give us a precursor just to kind of your background maybe how you got into therapy the kind of therapy you do and then that how that leads you into the your interest here and i mean it's interesting to me like the book that i'm the suspicious of is the one that's like i figured everything out and here is a system that integrates all things and never again will there ever need to be an innovation.
今天我们请到了亚历克斯·蒙克，他是一位治疗师，著有《创伤与超自然：鹰之翼与飞翔》一书。如果视频还在录制，我本来想做点道具喜剧，比如带上美国刻板印象的道具，戴着牛仔帽，拿着甜甜圈之类的。我没有枪，但你知道，作为伦敦人，这些是你的联想吗？是的，我想是的，就是那些常见的刻板印象。你的书非常引人入胜，而且你的视角在很多地方都有些与众不同。我所从事的很多工作，我觉得在临床实践中是不可避免且正在回归的，但它们往往具有争议性，或者说争议性不大，只是不太被理解。你能先介绍一下你的背景吗？比如你是如何进入治疗领域的，你从事什么样的治疗，以及这些经历如何引导你产生现在的兴趣？对我来说，我最怀疑的那种书就是声称“我已经搞清楚了一切，这里有一套整合了所有事物的系统，以后再也不需要任何创新了”。
And I distrust that kind of book a lot more than the person who's sort of honestly fleshing things out and hashing them out to see what they think themselves. And you can sort of see the author teaching himself as they're teaching the audience because it feels collaborative. It feels honest. And a lot of times those ideas are a little bit more timeless and universal. So I'd just love to hear about how you get there. Yeah, so, well, I guess my background was, I mean, my first degree was English literature. So I've always enjoyed reading and creative aspects of life so I also have a interest in the
我非常不信任那种书，相比之下，我更信任那些诚实地探索、推敲并试图弄清楚自己想法的人。你可以看到作者在教导读者的同时也在自我学习，这感觉像是一种协作，感觉很诚实。很多时候，这些想法更具永恒性和普遍性。所以我很想听听你是如何走到这一步的。好的，我的背景是，我的第一个学位是英国文学。所以我一直很喜欢阅读和生活的创造性方面，我也对艺术有兴趣，
art so very much visual art and I'm not a trained artist but I'm always been enjoyed painting and drawing and anything related to the arts and um i've also been a musician for a long time a performing musician um what kind of music um i guess it would be a kind of experimental folk folk music psychedelic folk um quite a lot um kind of like the the freak folk stuff of the 70s throwback that kind of world yeah yeah that's right and there was there was also um kind of like the the freak folk stuff of the 70s throwback that kind of world yeah yeah that's right and there was there was also yeah kind of like bert jansch that kind of thing john renborn and those sort of pentangle that kind of stuff but also in the states you may know bands like espers or six organs of admittance that kind of thing um so you're taking me back to like 2005. exactly so that is that
尤其是视觉艺术。我不是受过专业训练的艺术家，但我一直很喜欢绘画、素描以及任何与艺术相关的东西。我长期以来也是一名音乐家，一名表演音乐家。什么类型的音乐？我想大概是某种实验民谣、迷幻民谣。很多那种70年代复古的“怪异民谣”风格，那种世界。是的，没错。还有像伯特·詹什（Bert Jansch）、约翰·伦伯恩（John Renbourn）以及五角星乐队（Pentangle）那种风格。但在美国，你可能知道像Espers或Six Organs of Admittance这样的乐队。所以你把我带回了2005年左右。没错，就是那个
the new weird america kind of stuff. yeah you know i don't think i've ever met another person that was into that scene. i was very into that scene in college. it wasn't cool then and i haven't heard about it since or at least where i was you know. that was the college rock days where like every song had to be it had to be like an american with a fake english or australian accent it was like i am an english major my adjectives have lots of favor oh my narratives rail swell and that was like all that you could play on the radio yeah absolutely yeah so so so that was a very particular scene, wasn't it? Yeah. So, yeah.
“新怪异美国”之类的东西。是的，我想我从来没见过另一个也喜欢那个圈子的人。我在大学时非常沉迷那个圈子。那时它并不流行，从那以后我就没怎么听说过了，或者至少在我待的地方是这样。那是大学摇滚时代，每首歌听起来都像是美国人假装带着英国或澳大利亚口音。就像是“我是英语专业的，我的形容词很有韵味，我的叙事如潮水般涌动”，那是当时电台里唯一能播放的东西。是的，绝对是这样。所以那是一个非常独特的圈子，不是吗？是的。
Is it still out there? Are you still making it? Still doing music. I mean, not so much, especially when I was the last, well, kind of COVID came along. So that meant like performances were kind of cut, you know, weren't happening. And at that time, I was also writing writing my book so I haven't really done anything to be honest I've done a couple of gigs but I generally haven't done much so but I still like to kind of pick up my guitar and stuff but yeah it's um it's just time really um so yeah I've in terms of you know in terms of that but yeah I've been doing've in terms of, you know, in terms of that, but yeah, I've been doing some painting a bit more, you know, so more visual arts stuff. And so yeah, so I so that was the kind of
它现在还存在吗？你还在做音乐吗？还在做。不过没那么多了，尤其是新冠疫情出现之后。这意味着演出被取消了，没法进行了。那时我还在写书，所以老实说我没怎么做音乐。我做过几次演出，但总体来说没做太多。但我还是喜欢拿起吉他之类的，但确实，主要是时间问题。至于视觉艺术，我最近画得更多了。所以，这就是我
background that I sort of have come from. So I studied that, I guess, and I've always been interested in psychology and then I decided to study integrative arts psychotherapy which is basically a way to integrate the two for me that's why I decided to take that particular master's program and from which I graduated and then I went into generally in private practice I was working as part of a psychiatrist psychiatry practice for a while but that that the the psychiatrist retired so that was that so I've been since in in private practice and I kind of got the idea, you know, the idea of the curse position that kind of came organically, I guess, through reading Mark Fisher a lot, you know, his stuff, particularly the book Ghosts of My Life. of my life um and then obviously psychoanalysis um and i have a a strong interest in as you can probably gather from the book in spirituality as well and what i'm calling in the book magical consciousness broadly um western esotericism the occult and how that kind of feeds into trauma as well, the numinous, all of these kind of areas and kind of building it around this idea of the cursed position and how more broadly the supernatural relates to the practice of psychotherapy and the, and you probably got this from the book the kind of prejudices that we find when it comes to spirituality and as as as clinicians that we may
的背景。我学习了这些，而且我一直对心理学感兴趣，后来我决定学习整合艺术心理治疗，对我来说，这基本上是将两者结合的一种方式。这就是我决定参加那个硕士项目的原因，毕业后我进入了私人执业。我曾在一个精神科诊所工作过一段时间，但那位精神科医生退休了，所以我就开始独立执业。我产生“诅咒位置”这个想法，大概是通过大量阅读马克·费舍尔（Mark Fisher）的作品，特别是《我生命的幽灵》（Ghosts of My Life），然后显然还有精神分析。正如你从书中可能看出的，我对灵性也有浓厚的兴趣，我在书中称之为“魔法意识”，广义上包括西方秘术、神秘学，以及它们如何融入创伤、神圣感等领域。我围绕“诅咒位置”这个概念，以及超自然现象如何与心理治疗实践相关联来构建这些内容。你可能从书中也读到了，作为临床医生，我们在面对灵性时可能会有的偏见，
project on to our clients or our patients right so yeah because of our own um our our own religious beliefs you know conscious or unconscious yeah exactly unconscious, conscious or unconscious. Yeah, exactly. Unconscious or conscious or unconscious. Yes, it may be a religious belief, which is of a particular, you're a member of a particular organized religion and then you project that onto somebody else or one of your clients, or it could be a particularly strong,
我们可能会将其投射到我们的客户或病人身上。是的，因为我们自己……我们自己的宗教信仰，无论是有意识还是无意识的。是的，完全正确，无意识的、有意识的或无意识的。是的，这可能是一种宗教信仰，比如你是某个特定有组织宗教的成员，然后你将其投射到别人或你的客户身上，或者它可能是一种特别强烈的、
atheistic or materialistic belief that can be experienced as reductive or patronizing. Yeah, I see both of those would be damaging. I mean, Europe, like Britain, is going to be a little bit more post-Christian than the US is. Do you see, you know, religious practitioners that don't disclose it or something? Well, I guess that would depend on um well
无神论或唯物主义的信仰，这可能会被视为一种还原论或居高临下的态度。是的，我觉得这两者都会造成伤害。欧洲，比如英国，比美国更偏向后基督教时代。你见过不公开自己宗教信仰的从业者吗？嗯，我想这取决于……
obviously um if you know there you're into territory of conversion therapy uh which is particularly um uh toxic uh pernicious um I but of course it depends on what your modality is and what the relationship is with a particular client as to whether you're going to disclose that or not um but yeah i think that obviously these unconscious uh projections are are important that's why we go into psychotherapy ourselves right yeah yeah i mean i think um i usually lean yung usually lean in some of my conceptualizations and that whole idea that if the religious function is not conscious, that it will be projected and used unconsciously. And every time somebody calls me like a pseudoscientist because I do brain spotting or somatic therapy or something on LinkedIn, I'll look at their profile and it'll have like all of this like wildly religious and conspiratorial right-wing stuff while they're like what you're doing is not evidence-based and it's like you know you you see this kind of obsession with logic and reason empiricism inside of therapy a lot of times you know there's those those things get projected elsewhere so it's um i don't know it's interesting but you're
显然，如果你进入了“转化疗法”的领域，那是特别有毒且有害的。当然，这取决于你的治疗模式以及你与特定客户的关系，决定是否要披露这一点。但我认为，这些无意识的投射确实很重要，这就是为什么我们自己也要接受心理治疗的原因，对吧？是的，我通常倾向于荣格的观点，即如果宗教功能没有被意识到，它就会被投射并无意识地使用。每当有人在领英上因为我做脑点疗法（Brainspotting）或躯体疗法而称我为伪科学家时，我会查看他们的个人资料，发现上面充斥着狂热的宗教和阴谋论右翼内容，同时他们却在说“你做的事情没有循证依据”。你会发现，在治疗中，人们经常对逻辑、理性和经验主义有一种执念，这些东西被投射到了其他地方。所以，这很有趣，但你
saying also that somebody could be atheist and secularizing of somebody who's having a genuine kind of embodied experience and then they feel condescended to and that's damage. safe don't we um so we don't want to start idealizing um psychotic you know experiences as the numinous um which because there is obviously a crossover between the numinous and the and psychotism and it can be very difficult to differentiate between the two um but at the same time we we don't want to kind of denigrate somebody who has a particular spiritual or numinous experience, which really means something to them, you know, some particular kind of synchronicity, which, you know, which can be very powerful. And somebody says, oh, well, you know, that's, you know, it may not be that some of the therapists kind of openly says, oh, God, well, you know, that's just a coincidence, you know, but they may, you know, it could just be a kind of raised eyebrow says oh god well you know that's just a coincidence you know um but they may you know it could just be a kind of raised eyebrow or a slight movement of the body you know which can kind of indicate some sense of suspicion perhaps and um so i think it i think it is a it's important to explore these areas with with just with curiosity and openness isn't it and um yeah so that we don't kind of
也提到，一个人可能是无神论者，并对那些有真实具身化体验的人进行世俗化处理，这会让对方感到被轻视，从而造成伤害。我们不想开始将精神病性的体验理想化为“神圣感”，因为神圣感和精神病之间显然存在交叉，区分两者可能非常困难。但同时，我们也不想贬低那些有特定灵性或神圣体验的人，这对他们来说意义重大，比如某种同步性，这可能非常有力量。如果治疗师公开说“哦，天哪，那只是巧合”，或者仅仅是挑挑眉毛，或者身体有轻微的动作，这可能表现出某种怀疑。所以我认为，带着好奇心和开放的态度去探索这些领域很重要，
patronize or infantilize people yeah no we're just a silence sometimes i think the person brings something up about their spiritual practice or their you know faith multiple times and the therapist just leaves it there whereas anything else that a patient brings up over and over i mean the first lesson you know a lot of times in therapy schools if it comes up several times engage with it ask questions even if you don't know what it is yeah but they're kind of afraid to go there or afraid to follow the patient yeah and i think and i think and that's a really that's a really um a really interesting area and i think and again a difficult area because I think if you you know if somebody's coming to therapy they're coming to therapy because they they're having difficulties with
这样我们就不会居高临下或把人幼稚化。是的，有时候病人多次提到他们的灵性实践或信仰，治疗师却置之不理，而病人反复提到的任何其他事情，治疗学校的第一课通常就是：如果它多次出现，就去参与它，去提问，即使你不知道那是什么。但他们害怕去触碰，或者害怕跟随病人的思路。我认为这是一个非常有趣的领域，但也确实很困难。因为如果有人来做治疗，他们是因为在
something they're suffering right that's why they go to therapy right most of the time almost all of the time and so I think we if somebody has a particular experience, it's something that can be looked at from a spiritual perspective, you know, in terms of its connection, say, to the Jungian's biggest self, you know, in terms of a larger cosmological sort of constellation of reality, if you like but it also um may also they also need to speak about their relationship to their caregivers and what it means from that perspective and it and it will also have meaning and i think so i think in therapy we don't really we we need to have curiosity and so if there is a sense that there's something which is off limits then obviously I think that's something that needs to, and it keeps coming back, then obviously that's something that needs to be addressed, isn't it? And some of the language around the curse position that you're describing reminds me of James Hellman talking about constellation, which is taking that from astrology, but he would talk about as a way of not pathologizing somebody and making things more of like a system of forces that we're trying to find equilibrium would say,
某些方面遇到了困难，他们在受苦，对吧？这就是他们来治疗的原因。所以如果有人有某种体验，可以从灵性的角度来看待，比如它与荣格的“大我”的联系，或者从更宏大的宇宙现实结构来看。但同时，他们也需要谈论他们与照顾者的关系，从那个角度来看它意味着什么。我认为在治疗中，我们需要保持好奇心。如果感觉到有什么东西是禁区，而它又不断出现，那么显然这是需要解决的问题，不是吗？你描述的关于“诅咒位置”的一些语言，让我想起詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）谈论的“星位”（constellation），他借用了占星术的术语，但他将其作为一种不将人病理化、而是将其视为一种我们试图寻找平衡的力场系统的方法，会说：
you know, this part of you is constellating, you know, this thing in the world, meaning that it's temporary, that it's just a part of you, you know, helping them get distance on something,
“你身上的这一部分正在与世界上的某件事形成星位”，这意味着它是暂时的，它只是你的一部分，这能帮助他们与某事保持距离。
even while experiencing it, you know, in a profoundly affecting way. Could you say a little bit about why the language of the supernatural is useful you know why bring that into therapy and how you see it help you know clinically um do you how do you mean by bringing in the language of the supernatural well a curse right i mean the curse is always a medical condition so yeah yeah which dsm number is that or icd-10 or whatever there yeah so i guess yeah so with the curse i think so if i mean freud's called had came up with something similar called i don't
即使在深刻地体验它时也是如此。你能谈谈为什么使用“超自然”的语言是有用的吗？为什么要把这些带入治疗中？你如何看待它在临床上的帮助？你所说的“引入超自然语言”是什么意思？嗯，诅咒，对吧？诅咒总是一种医疗状况，所以……那是DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）的哪个编号，还是ICD-10之类的？所以，关于诅咒，我想如果弗洛伊德提出了一个类似的概念，叫做……
sorry i don't know this kind of particular you know i know a little bit of hillman but i don't know that particular idea of the constellation but um fre across this idea, came up with this idea called fate neurosis right where you have this what he calls like a demonic, demonic psychological entity if you like which keeps coming back and repeating and a person keeps having these kind of events that keep happening which are kind of inexplicable you know they just keep having bad luck and bad things keep happening to them but it's like well but it can't even really be attributed to anything in particular so but like I think this was later on in Freud's career. So he'd kind of abandoned the whole kind of real trauma and replaced it with the unconscious fantasy, right? So by this stage, he wasn't really looking
抱歉，我不了解这个特定的概念，我只了解一点希尔曼，但我不了解那个“星位”的想法。但弗洛伊德提出了一个叫做“命运神经症”（fate neurosis）的概念，即他所说的某种“恶魔般的”心理实体，它不断重复出现，一个人不断经历那些无法解释的事件，他们总是走霉运，坏事不断发生，但却无法归因于任何特定的事物。我想这是弗洛伊德职业生涯后期提出的。那时他已经放弃了真正的创伤，转而用无意识幻想来代替。所以在这个阶段，他并没有真正关注
at trauma. So that's where I kind of brought in, brought, if you like, brought back in a way, think of it in those Freudian terms, bringing back the trauma as a means of explaining this repetition compulsion. The reason for the curses is because the way that the person experiences this repetition can seem like a supernatural entity, as if this inexplicable thing that keeps happening to them. They experience it as if it's outside of them, you know, as if somebody has a special power or some entity has some particular supernatural power to cause this person misfortune. So hence the curse. And it has some parallels with you you see or what you
创伤。所以我以某种方式重新引入了它，用弗洛伊德的术语来思考，将创伤作为解释这种“强迫性重复”的一种手段。诅咒之所以存在，是因为一个人体验这种重复的方式看起来就像一个超自然实体，仿佛某种无法解释的事情不断发生在他们身上。他们体验到它仿佛是在他们之外，就好像某人拥有特殊的力量，或者某种实体拥有某种特定的超自然力量来给这个人带来不幸。因此就有了“诅咒”。它与你所看到的……
saw during the um the witch trials um in the early modern period where you know people are accused of being witches and and are cursing uh their neighbors and so forth right so it's something like some but but the the kind of phenomenological kind of nature of the psychological experience feels a bit like that. So it's very, very, very powerful. So that's the connection with the kind of the supernatural rather than it just being a purely materialistic phenomenon. well i think uh anybody who does any sort of practice that works with dreams i mean you definitely see um there be pretty traditional kind of like curses and monsters show up um you know and like a lot of times if i have a patient who is thinking about making a big life change to get healthy maybe they don't want to drink anymore or they're gonna do something but it is you know i in
在近代早期的女巫审判中，人们被指控为女巫，并诅咒他们的邻居等等。所以这在心理体验的现象学本质上感觉有点像那样。所以它非常、非常强大。这就是它与超自然的联系，而不是仅仅将其视为一种纯粹的唯物主义现象。我认为任何从事梦境工作的人，肯定会看到非常传统的诅咒和怪物出现。如果我有一个病人正在考虑做出重大生活改变以变得健康，比如他们不想再喝酒了，或者他们要做某事，但在
the back of my head i'm saying okay the unlived life of the parent though no one in your family has done this or you were raised to feel like this is not something that you deserve or can do then you know i'm and i'm that's in the back of my head two weeks later when they start to have dreams about you know a werewolf gene in their body or you know a vampire looking in the window these things watching them whereas it's like does it feel like you're cursed does it feel like you're haunted like you can't get away from this thing that's somehow in you you know epigenetically yeah absolutely yeah and and epigenetically kind of um feeds in i guess doesn't it to the intergenerational aspect of it the
我的脑海深处，我会想：好吧，这是父母未活出的人生，尽管你家里没人做过这种事，或者你从小就被教育觉得你不配或做不到。两周后，当他们开始做关于身体里有狼人基因，或者窗外有吸血鬼盯着他们的梦时，我会问：这感觉像是被诅咒了吗？感觉像是被缠住了吗？就像你无法摆脱某种不知何故存在于你体内的东西，某种表观遗传学上的东西？是的，绝对是。而且表观遗传学在某种程度上确实融入了它的代际层面。
intergenerational aspect of the trauma which of course we're we're not conscious of we don't know what what our ancestors have passed down to us and like you know those those kind of ancestral elements can appear in dreams as well um those or those familial um kind of constructs or you know objects whatever language or metaphor you want to use to represent them they quite they do they do stalk the unconscious and um that was another another book that was a big influence on me was my work was uh i probably know this is quite famous the donald cowshed's book uh yeah yeah i was going to ask if you had read a similar yeah the inner world of trauma so yeah and you know i was thinking trauma in the soul was the one that i don't know
创伤的代际层面，当然我们对此并不知情，我们不知道祖先传给了我们什么，就像你知道的那样，这些祖先的元素也会出现在梦中，嗯，那些家庭的结构，或者你知道的客体，无论你想用什么语言或隐喻来代表它们，它们确实在潜意识中徘徊，嗯，这是另一本对我影响很大的书，我的工作是，呃，我可能知道这很有名，唐纳德·考舍德（Donald Kalsched）的书，是的，是的，我正想问你是否读过类似的书，是的，《创伤的内在世界》，所以是的，你知道，我在想《创伤与灵魂》是我不知道的那一本。
that one actually i've only read uh that one uh the inner world of trauma trauma in the soul has a lot of possession and angels and things showing up you know it's like yeah yeah so um so yeah that definitely where you've and and so i i think these kind of yeah these entities in the deepest layers of the unconscious that's very kind of cow shit as well um but it is interesting because you also have that in psychoanalysis as well because melanie klein talks about the the deepest layers of the unconscious, you know, in a similar way to kind of Jung did, which you wouldn't kind of expect from Melanie Klein, that, you know, below the unconscious there's a deeper layer
那本我其实只读过，呃，那本，呃，《创伤的内在世界》，《创伤与灵魂》里有很多关于附身、天使和各种显现的内容，你知道，就像，是的，是的，所以，嗯，所以是的，这绝对是你已经，而且，所以我认为这些，是的，这些潜意识最深层的实体，这也非常考舍德风格，嗯，但这很有趣，因为你在精神分析中也有这种情况，因为梅兰妮·克莱因（Melanie Klein）谈论潜意识的最深层时，你知道，方式和荣格（Jung）类似，你可能不会从梅兰妮·克莱因那里预料到这一点，即，你知道，在潜意识之下还有一个更深层。
where we have these kind of entities which are kind of coming up. And she calls that, you know, but in in melanie klein's terms this isn't related to an archetypal system it's related to an archaic mother you know an archaic relationship with the mother right so but it is there are some interesting crossovers and and i can't remember where i heard this but um somebody once said that the reason why you get these weird crossovers with Jung and Klein was because they're built, you know, they were basically next door to each other at one point, their training institutes. So yeah, so you've got this kind of weird, and also you have that in the, still today in the training, one of the Jungian trainings
在那里我们有这些正在浮现的实体。她称之为，你知道，但在梅兰妮·克莱因的术语中，这与原型系统无关，它与古老的母亲有关，你知道，与母亲的古老关系，对吧，所以确实有一些有趣的交叉点，我不记得是在哪里听到的，但是，嗯，有人曾经说，你之所以在荣格和克莱因之间看到这些奇怪的交叉，是因为他们基本上是在隔壁，他们的培训机构。所以是的，所以你有这种奇怪的，而且在今天，在培训中，其中一个荣格培训中也有这种情况。
here is very Kleinian anyway i'm going off they also work with psychotic yeah i mean i think a lot of times when you're working with schizophrenia you see deeper layers of the psyche it may take years to get to you know just in talk therapy at the surface level yeah absolutely absolutely so but i think i think with, in terms of the curse position and this archaic unconscious is very important because it's the archaic unconscious which can actually, which actually is related to the spiritual or the numinous experience, right?
这里无论如何都是非常克莱因派的，我跑题了，他们也处理精神病，是的，我的意思是，我认为很多时候当你处理精神分裂症时，你会看到心灵的更深层，可能需要几年时间才能达到，你知道，仅仅在表层的谈话疗法中，是的，绝对是，绝对是，所以，但我认为，就诅咒位置和这种古老的潜意识而言，这非常重要，因为正是这种古老的潜意识实际上与精神或神圣体验有关，对吧？
To the synchronicities that we have, the dreams that we have that mean something to us and and again coming back to cal shed i can't remember it's a long time i read since i read that book but i think he's saying and i'm sure jung would have probably agreed with this that you know that there was there's a healing isn't there that that that that's that's where we can find the healing from those deepest elements of the unconscious. It's not coming from the ego, it's through this unification as much as possible. But where I sort of differ from Jung, and againpal system, I kind of I I go along with that up to a point.
与我们拥有的共时性，与我们拥有的对我们有意义的梦有关，再次回到考舍德，我不记得了，我读那本书已经很久了，但我认为他在说，我相信荣格可能也会同意这一点，你知道，有一种治愈，不是吗，那就是我们可以在潜意识的最深层元素中找到治愈的地方。它不是来自自我，而是通过尽可能多的统一。但我与荣格有所不同，再次回到原型系统，我在某种程度上是赞同的。
But then I feel I kind of diverge from it in other ways, because for the first reason is because I feel like sometimes it's very becomes very much you experience can is in danger of becoming universalized a little bit through these archetypes and the archetypal system and through the collective unconscious um and can take away from very unique subjective experience set um and secondly i think that i and it's interesting because you had a guest on your show i can't remember the gentleman's name sorry but he was talking about the aztecs it was very interesting i've only said james maffey yeah yeah yeah he was he was great really interesting and he was talking about the symbol um you know and you were kind of talking about the Jungian analyst and all of this, and like, I think that, and our sort of Western perspective of art, and he's saying no, for the Aztecs that wasn't art actually,
但后来我觉得我在其他方面与它分道扬镳了，因为第一个原因是，我觉得有时它变得非常，你的体验有通过这些原型、原型系统和集体潜意识被普遍化的危险，嗯，并且可能会削弱非常独特的个人体验，其次，我认为，而且这很有趣，因为你的节目里有一位嘉宾，我不记得那位先生的名字了，抱歉，但他谈到了阿兹特克人，这非常有趣，我只说了詹姆斯·马菲（James Maffei），是的，是的，他很棒，非常有趣，他谈到了符号，你知道，你当时在谈论荣格分析师和所有这些，而且，我想，以及我们那种西方艺术视角，他在说不，对于阿兹特克人来说，那实际上不是艺术，
and so it's our sort of, and this isn't only Jung, it's across the whole of psychotherapy really, you know, this kind of, and perhaps we can say Western, modern Western culture as a whole, the fixation with the symbol, the need to symbolize, we always kind of need to, as he said, your guest said, re-present rather than present, right? So that was very, very interesting. And I think, again, coming back to what I was saying earlier about being reductive in psychotherapy, we can be in danger of again of doing that if this sort of oh so this means this or this means that or this is that you know and the interpretation becomes like the the cage that you can't see outside of and i think hillman talks about that doesn't he and dream and the underworld like our our need to interpret dreams right we need to kind of row back on that a bit and kind of see the dream for
所以这是我们的一种，而且这不仅仅是荣格，它实际上贯穿了整个心理治疗，你知道，这种，也许我们可以说整个现代西方文化，对符号的固着，对符号化的需求，我们总是需要，正如他所说，你的嘉宾所说，再现而不是呈现，对吧？所以这非常非常有趣。而且我认为，再次回到我之前说的关于心理治疗中的还原论，如果我们陷入这种“哦，所以这意味着这个，或者这意味着那个，或者这是那个”，我们可能会有再次这样做的危险，你知道，解释变成了你无法看透的笼子，我想希尔曼（Hillman）谈到了这一点，不是吗，在梦和冥界中，我们对解释梦的需求，对吧，我们需要在这方面稍微退后一点，并以某种方式看待梦，
what it actually is, what it's telling us rather than interpreting it through a sort of symbolic structure. Yeah, and Hillman had an interest in turning, you're talking about the monism of Jung being kind of threatening for that to be monadic and that everything goes back around to, you know, some source. I mean, Hillman broke that source apart into almost a polytheistic way that, I mean, I think he never really found a language for the system. Like he had a critique, but he never really built the system to kind of implement that perspective. And I think that conversation is still kind of happening with the post
它实际上是什么，它在告诉我们什么，而不是通过某种符号结构来解释它。是的，希尔曼对转向很感兴趣，你在谈论荣格的一元论，认为它是单子的，一切都回到了某种源头，这有点令人担忧。我的意思是，希尔曼把那个源头拆解成了一种几乎是多神论的方式，我的意思是，我认为他从未真正为这个系统找到一种语言。就像他有批评，但他从未真正建立起一个系统来实现那种视角。而且我认为这种对话在后荣格派中仍在进行。
Jungians. A lot of them are more experiential or somatic. I mean, the most interesting models to me are the people that left the psychoanalytic and the depth psychology institutes, you know, in the 70s and 80s to make more kind of embodied and experiential models. Those people didn't have a whole lot of influence then, but I see their stuff coming back now. Yes, I can imagine with all the kind of, because with all the trauma literature as well, it's kind of empirically proving or, you know, proving that this was, you know, valid, right, essentially. Well, valid is a weak adjective, but yeah. Yeah, perennial maybe.
荣格派。他们中的许多人更注重体验或躯体。我的意思是，对我来说最有趣的模型是那些在70年代和80年代离开精神分析和深度心理学研究所的人，你知道，为了制造更具具身性和体验性的模型。那些人在当时并没有太大的影响力，但我现在看到他们的东西又回来了。是的，我可以想象，因为所有的创伤文献，它在某种程度上是在经验上证明，或者，你知道，证明这是，你知道，有效的，对吧，本质上。嗯，有效是一个弱形容词，但是的。是的，也许是永恒的。
I mean that, you know, people notice this phenomenologically. Now we have tools to kind of understand it neurologically but it's the same information you know it's a new discovery yeah yeah so could you give some ideas of like just for the people listening where that's kind of a heady concept like how you implement this in the room not a case study necessarily unless you want to you know anonymize longer um yeah one more generic but could you talk about like you know when you're working with the curse position here's where you define things here's where the person gets out and here's here's the technique maybe yeah so so i think well obviously it depends on what the the presentation is but i think broadly um my approach is an integrative one.
我的意思是，你知道，人们在现象学上注意到了这一点。现在我们有了工具在神经学上理解它，但这是同样的信息，你知道，这是一个新发现，是的，是的，所以你能给一些想法，就像对于听众来说，这是一个令人费解的概念，你如何在咨询室中实施这一点，不一定是一个案例研究，除非你想，你知道，匿名化，更长，嗯，是的，更通用，但你能谈谈，你知道，当你处理这里的诅咒位置时，你在这里定义事物，这里是人走出来的地方，这里是技术，也许，是的，所以我认为，嗯，显然这取决于呈现的是什么，但我认为大体上，我的方法是一种整合的方法。
And what I mean by that is that I be thinking about what the meaning of the curse is for the particular individual, what that means to them. And does it have, is it purely that they see it as a psychological aspect of themselves or do they actually see it as coming from the outside do they see it as an external or supernatural threat to the person and so I'd be looking at it from those perspectives and I would be exploring it through the relationship so I'd be working very much through a psychodynamic frame working with the relationship how the um what working with my own countertransference working with my own experiences of the person who's sitting in front of me and if there is a particular traumatic element to it, then I may or may not use EMDR, which can be very, very helpful with traumatic experiences, particularly with, well, with relational or developmental trauma, as you know, right? So, but I think it's very important to think about how to help the person to think about how that they're identifying with the curse.
我的意思是，我会思考诅咒对特定个人意味着什么，这对他们意味着什么。它是否，他们是否纯粹将其视为自己心理的一个方面，还是他们实际上将其视为来自外部，他们是否将其视为对个人的外部或超自然威胁，所以我将从这些角度来看待它，我将通过关系来探索它，所以我将在很大程度上通过心理动力学框架工作，处理关系，处理我自己的反移情，处理我坐在我面前的人的经历，如果其中有一个特定的创伤元素，那么我可能会也可能不会使用EMDR，这对于创伤经历非常有帮助，特别是对于，嗯，对于关系或发展性创伤，如你所知，对吧？所以，但我认为思考如何帮助人们思考他们如何认同诅咒是非常重要的。
Right. So because the curse position is very much a place of powerlessness, helplessness. And there's this sense of something very aggressive, which is continually coming back to the person which is haunting them so so first of all explore somebody's obviously somebody's family history and where they think this may be coming from what what does the curse mean to them but then also to think about their own their own aggression what they angry about, what's causing the rage, because often there can be, with the curse, there can be very strong internalised object or entity, which is very attacking, psychoanalytically a super ego,
对。因为诅咒位置在很大程度上是一个无力感、无助感的地方。而且有一种非常具有攻击性的东西的感觉，它不断地回到那个人身边，困扰着他们，所以首先要探索某人的家庭历史，他们认为这可能来自哪里，诅咒对他们意味着什么，但也要思考他们自己的攻击性，他们对什么感到愤怒，是什么导致了愤怒，因为通常，对于诅咒，可能会有一个非常强大的内在化客体或实体，它是非常有攻击性的，精神分析上的超我，
which, you know, you're useless, you're rubbish, you're not going to do anything, you're not going to achieve anything in your life so to to enable the person to think about what that might mean to them so it might be like you were kind of saying like it could be a neglectful or an abusive parent that they're identifying with um and through and through their identification with that particular um internal object if you like, that internalized parent or caregiver, they're destroying their own lives, right? They're kind of just tearing themselves to pieces. an addiction or it could be through damaging relationships or it could be by protecting an internalized perpetrator of of abuse you know so that they keep kind of going back to
你知道，你没用，你是垃圾，你什么也做不了，你这辈子什么也成就不了，所以要使那个人能够思考这对他们可能意味着什么，所以它可能就像你刚才说的那样，它可能是一个他们所认同的疏忽或虐待的父母，嗯，通过他们对那个特定的内在客体的认同，如果你愿意的话，那个内在化的父母或照顾者，他们正在摧毁自己的生活，对吧？他们有点只是把自己撕成碎片。成瘾，或者它可能是通过破坏性的关系，或者它可能是通过保护一个内在化的虐待施暴者，你知道，所以他们不断地回到
the abusive caregiver and they keep kind of going along with that so i think is with in terms of treatment in my experience the internal world is shifted by what the person does in the external world so if they if if they if therapy can help somebody to go back to through the through the positive relationship through with the therapist right through the experiences of having if you like a good object yeah that they've kind of internalized through the therapy then they can start to kind of stand up to people you know the bullies in their life they can start putting boundaries up in their lives you know and start to say no to people they can start to develop and in their lives, you know, and start to say no to people. They can start to develop and then start to develop more healthy relationships, which are not only based on, say, self-destruction or transgression.
虐待性的照顾者，他们不断地顺从，所以我认为就治疗而言，根据我的经验，内在世界是通过人在外在世界所做的事情而改变的，所以如果治疗可以帮助某人通过积极的关系，通过与治疗师的关系，对吧，通过拥有一个好的客体，如果你愿意的话，他们通过治疗内在化了，那么他们就可以开始站起来对抗人们，你知道，他们生活中的恶霸，他们可以开始在生活中建立界限，你知道，并开始对人们说不，他们可以开始发展，在他们的生活中，你知道，并开始对人们说不。他们可以开始发展，然后开始发展更健康的关系，这些关系不仅基于，比如说，自我毁灭或越轨。
They can be based on cherishing other people, tenderness, care, all of these things. And then they can start to to do that and then that that then calms down this kind of harsh kind of cursing um super ego in there and and and so i think when it comes to exploring the spiritual aspects of somebody's experience that that then can the once they've gone through those stages then they can really think about the spiritual aspects of their lives as something which is much more grounded that they can participate in. of see um you can see um spiritual experiences as a kind of way to avoid all of the things that i've i've been talking about um yeah so i think so i think that's in in the broad brush strokes that's the way i kind of work really yeah so i mean i i think an another thing um is i think you say this in some of the marketing materials for the book, but that this doesn't even though, you know, a lot of times, you know, people need to clarify that in therapy, but this is just kind of an open-ended language where we
它们可以基于珍惜他人、温柔、关怀，所有这些事情。然后他们可以开始这样做，然后这就会平息内在那种严厉的诅咒超我，所以我想当探索某人经历的精神层面时，一旦他们经历了这些阶段，他们就可以真正思考他们生活的精神层面，将其视为一种更扎实的东西，他们可以参与其中。看到，你可以看到精神体验是一种避免我一直在谈论的所有事情的方式，嗯，是的，所以我认为这就是大体上我工作的方式，真的，是的，所以我的意思是，我认为另一件事，嗯，是我想你在书的一些营销材料中提到了这一点，但这甚至，你知道，很多时候，你知道，人们需要在治疗中澄清这一点，但这只是一种开放式的语言，我们
can have a conversation that's useful, you know. Absolutely, absolutely. But, you know, obviously you will come, there will be conflict, there's conflict in the therapeutic relationship that will come up. I mean, if somebody feels that they are cursed, right, they're not going to have, you know, whether the curse is a metaphor or if they think they actually are cursed, you know, either way, they are not going to be seeing you as a benign object right as a therapist so
可以进行有用的对话，你知道。绝对，绝对。但是，你知道，显然你会遇到，治疗关系中会有冲突，会出现冲突。我的意思是，如果有人觉得他们被诅咒了，对吧，他们不会有，你知道，无论诅咒是一个隐喻，还是他们认为他们真的被诅咒了，你知道，无论哪种方式，他们都不会把你视为一个良性的客体，对吧，作为治疗师，所以
i think as a therapist you have to hold a lot of kind of negative transference right and you need to be able to explore that with curiosity with the person and yeah they may think that you're you know that you have a you know they could have all kinds of fantasies around what kind of belief you have you know whether you're whatever the color of your skin whatever clothes you wear right however whatever your accent is etc etc and they've come to you for a reason right there's pre-transference they've heard things about you they'll have ideas when they come into into the room so all of these things are important aren't they yeah usually um it's the the freudians that give me a pushback for being too like woo if i write something or whatever they'll say like you know well this this isn't evidence-based or this is too out there but
我认为作为治疗师，你必须承受很多负面移情，对吧，你需要能够带着好奇心与那个人探索这一点，是的，他们可能认为你，你知道，你有一个，你知道，他们可能对你有什么样的信仰有各种各样的幻想，你知道，无论你是，无论你的肤色是什么，无论你穿什么衣服，对吧，无论你的口音是什么等等，他们来找你是有原因的，对吧，有预移情，他们听说过关于你的事情，当他们进入房间时，他们会有想法，所以所有这些事情都很重要，不是吗？是的，通常，是弗洛伊德派的人因为我太“巫术”而推开我，如果我写了什么东西或者其他什么，他们会说，你知道，好吧，这不是基于证据的，或者这太离谱了，但是
evidence-based from freudians yeah that's okay i I've seen Jungians try and hide behind it too, which is always kind of funny. Okay. The depths of phenomenology, except science is useful, you know, when we want to not look at something. But what is it? I don't... There was somebody that I was talking to at a conference,
基于证据的，来自弗洛伊德派，是的，没关系，我也见过荣格派的人试图躲在它后面，这总是有点好笑。好的。现象学的深度，除了科学是有用的，你知道，当我们不想看某样东西时。但它是什么？我不……有一个我在会议上交谈过的人，
and are you familiar with Eric Byrne game theory? Yeah, the transactional analysis, yeah. Yeah, where he's putting Freud together with John Nash, at a conference and um are you familiar with like eric burn you like game theory yeah the transactional analysis yeah yeah where he's like putting freud together with john nash i guess game theory and and uh right yeah psychoanalysis but you know they were they liked that background and they were saying like okay what's wrong with talking about a curse like what is a curse right what is bluebeard about right you know domestic abuse what is you know and i'm blanking the name but the myth where the daughters are dancing all along and they look drowsy and the dad's saying what's wrong and they can't talk about what's happening at night and their shoes are worn out on the bottom because they're dancing all night long
你熟悉埃里克·伯恩（Eric Berne）的游戏理论吗？是的，交流分析，是的。是的，他在会议上把弗洛伊德和约翰·纳什（John Nash）放在一起，嗯，你熟悉埃里克·伯恩吗，你喜欢游戏理论，是的，交流分析，是的，是的，他在那里把弗洛伊德和约翰·纳什放在一起，我想是博弈论，还有，嗯，对，是的，精神分析，但是你知道，他们喜欢那个背景，他们说，好吧，谈论诅咒有什么错，什么是诅咒，对吧，蓝胡子是关于什么的，对吧，你知道，家庭虐待，什么是，你知道，我忘了名字，但那个女儿们一直在跳舞，看起来昏昏欲睡，爸爸问怎么了，她们不能谈论晚上发生了什么，她们的鞋底磨损了，因为她们整晚都在跳舞的神话。
and he has to figure out why they're going into the fairy world and break it like what you know what is this about you know danger to your children this secret you know a secret thing that's affecting the house that you can't see that you know as a father you're supposed to be able to protect your daughters you know like this is this is just like the games we play like you're coming in you're saying what is the problem how do i fix it what is the riddle or the game to get out of to get out of this thing and you know when people are saying what's the point of talking about these things in in kind of mythological language i think i was talking about marie von franz or something and it was like because it's the same thing as the patient knows how to play this game they're continuing to play the same game that they
他必须弄清楚他们为什么要进入仙境，并打破它，你知道，这到底是怎么回事？你知道，这对你的孩子来说是一种危险，这种秘密，你知道，一种影响着房子却看不见的秘密事物，作为父亲，你本应该能够保护你的女儿，你知道，这就像我们玩的游戏，你走进来，你说问题是什么，我该如何解决它，有什么谜题或游戏可以摆脱这种困境，你知道，当人们说用这种神话语言谈论这些事情有什么意义时，我想我当时在谈论玛丽·冯·弗朗茨（Marie von Franz）之类的人，就像是因为这和病人知道如何玩这个游戏是一样的，他们继续玩着他们在
learned in their family consciously or unconsciously we're helping them get out that's what these myths are about too you know bluebeard is how do you you know that you kind of know the domestic abuse is there but how do you continue to make enough contact with your yourself have enough pride as a woman have enough assertiveness to get out of the situation and ask for help or to explore you know look at the thing that you are afraid of before it kills you it's all the same thing to me you know, look at the thing that you are afraid of before it kills you. It's all the same thing to me, you know. Absolutely, absolutely. And I think when the, I mean, the myth thing is an interesting one clinically, isn't it? Because I think if the person has to bring in, I mean, the patient that has to bring in their own myths, right, whatever it might be, it might be any, it could be a Netflix show.
家庭中有意识或无意识地学到的同一个游戏，我们正在帮助他们走出来，这就是这些神话的意义所在，你知道蓝胡子（Bluebeard）就是关于你如何，你知道，你其实知道家庭暴力就在那里，但你如何继续与自己保持足够的联系，作为女性拥有足够的自尊，拥有足够的自信来摆脱这种处境并寻求帮助，或者去探索，你知道，在你害怕的事情杀死你之前去审视它，对我来说这都是一回事，你知道，在你害怕的事情杀死你之前去审视它。对我来说这都是一回事，你知道。绝对是，绝对是。而且我认为，我的意思是，神话在临床上是一个有趣的话题，不是吗？因为我认为如果一个人必须引入，我的意思是，病人必须引入他们自己的神话，对吧，无论它可能是什么，它可能是任何东西，它可能是一部网飞（Netflix）剧集。
It could be, you you know that they're talking about the you know um oedipus rex or whatever you know any and any anything in between those things right um and i think sometimes i've i've thought oh it'd be great what a great idea to bring this i might mention this kind of myth and i'll kind of feel quite young and kind of intellectual and i've done that and actually it's like and it's fallen flat you know it means nothing and it doesn't have any bearing on that person's kind of deep uh psychological material right so so i've really kind of been conscious not to kind of bring that in. Yeah.
它可能是，你知道他们正在谈论俄狄浦斯王（Oedipus Rex）或者其他什么，你知道任何介于这些事物之间的东西，对吧，嗯，我想有时我曾想过，把这个带进来是个好主意，我可能会提到这种神话，我会感觉自己很年轻，很有知识分子气息，我确实这样做过，但实际上它就像，它反响平平，你知道，它毫无意义，对那个人的深层心理素材没有任何影响，对吧，所以我真的很有意识地不去引入这些东西。是的。
But yeah, definitely. I think with von Franz, you know, that's the kind of genius of Jung and von Franz, isn't it? That if you can get, if you do have that sense of mutuality about the myth, if they can really kind of, you know, and that kind of Pinkola Estes book as well about the wolves, if you can really get into that, find a way to get down in there with the person, then it's absolutely brilliant. But I think that takes real skill to kind of be able to do that,
但是，是的，绝对是。我认为对于冯·弗朗茨来说，你知道，这就是荣格和冯·弗朗茨的天才之处，不是吗？如果你能得到，如果你确实对神话有一种相互理解的感觉，如果他们真的能，你知道，还有平科拉·埃斯特斯（Pinkola Estes）那本关于狼的书，如果你能真正深入其中，找到一种方法与那个人一起深入下去，那么这绝对是绝妙的。但我认为这需要真正的技巧才能做到这一点，
that's what I mean. What about anime and video games? I mean, I see that be the mythological system of everybody under 30 who comes in. because a lot of the a lot of the anime i know or the video game i know and then some of them i don't i don't really have i have you know if it's if it's not 10 years old i probably don't know what it is um but when they're talking about it you know they're telling you like yeah so there's two brothers but one brother's cursed and that brother is bad but he's really the real hero because whatever and it's like i don't know the story but it's just like this is mythology like these are yeah i do know the story even though i don't know this video game so i think maybe coming in and being like let me teach you
这就是我的意思。那动漫和电子游戏呢？我的意思是，我看到那是所有30岁以下来访者的神话系统。因为我了解很多动漫或电子游戏，有些我不了解，我真的没有，你知道，如果它不是10年前的，我可能不知道它是什么，嗯，但当他们谈论它时，你知道，他们告诉你，比如，是的，有两个兄弟，但一个兄弟被诅咒了，那个兄弟很坏，但他实际上是真正的英雄，因为什么什么，就像我不知道这个故事，但这就像这就是神话，就像这些是，是的，我确实知道这个故事，即使我不知道这个电子游戏，所以我认为也许走进来，表现得像让我教你
about edifice is is that kind of dry my bow ties you know spinning around and they're confused about you know but uh mythology is is uh is there you know whether or not you see it you know it's not absolutely absolutely yeah that that but that kind of yeah that fusty sort of uh analyst or therapist is is kind of yeah not not not not a thing to be desired these days i think we have to find ways of kind of well there's nothing new about that right of connecting with our our clients right sure so and but i mean a lot of the book is about taking this beyond metaphor that it doesn't have to represent like it may be a metaphor and that it isn't a metaphysical reality but it isn't a metaphor and that this is a reality that we're dealing with in the room because the
关于俄狄浦斯，那是一种枯燥的，我的领结，你知道，转来转去，他们对你知道的事情感到困惑，但是，嗯，神话就在那里，你知道，无论你是否看到它，你知道，它不是，绝对是，绝对是，是的，那种，那种古板的分析师或治疗师，确实，嗯，不是现在人们所渴望的那种东西，我认为我们必须找到方法，嗯，这没什么新鲜的，对吧，与我们的客户建立联系，对吧，当然，所以，我的意思是，这本书的很大一部分是关于超越隐喻，它不必代表，比如它可能是一个隐喻，它不是一个形而上学的现实，但它不是一个隐喻，这是我们在房间里处理的一个现实，因为
person feels this way you know can you say anything about that kind of phenomenology and what you write? Yeah, could you just say, open that up a little bit more so I can kind of... Well, I think a lot of times people, there's an insecurity in that people feel like, well, you know, and I feel I get a little bit of that. I understand a little bit of it, but there's, because even on here, it's like I don't want to over-qualify things sometimes in case it's somebody's first episode or whatever. I get a little bit of that. I understand a little bit of it, but there's a,
那个人有这种感觉，你知道，你能说点关于那种现象学和你所写的东西吗？是的，你能稍微展开讲讲吗，这样我就可以……嗯，我认为很多时候人们，有一种不安全感，人们觉得，嗯，你知道，我觉得我有一点那种感觉。我理解一点，但有，因为即使在这里，就像我有时不想过度限定事物，以防这是某人的第一集之类的。我有一点那种感觉。我理解一点，但有，
cause even on here, it's like, I don't want to over qualify things sometimes in case it's somebody's first episode or whatever, but you have a lot of times we say something and we feel like we have to pick between, well, here is the metaphorical interpretation of this. This isn't really real,
因为即使在这里，就像我有时不想过度限定事物，以防这是某人的第一集之类的，但你有很多时候我们说了一些话，我们觉得我们必须在两者之间做出选择，嗯，这是对此的隐喻性解释。这并不是真的，
but there's a psychological reality that the curse is describing. And then over here where we're saying i believe in magic i'm gonna bury a duck egg at mcgnite and burn sage and i think that this is just as empirical as um kind of behavioral therapy and i and i think sometimes trying to to talk about the metaphysical reality of the world like i'm a therapist not a priest if you're bringing a reality into the office, I'll inhabit it with you in almost kind of a shamanic way. And we'll be there together. And I'm not really trying to qualify or think about what,
但有一个诅咒所描述的心理现实。然后在这里，我们说我相信魔法，我要在午夜埋下一颗鸭蛋，烧鼠尾草，我认为这和行为疗法一样是经验性的，嗯，我认为有时试图谈论世界的形而上学现实，就像我是一个治疗师，而不是牧师，如果你把一个现实带进办公室，我会以一种近乎萨满的方式与你共同居住。我们会在一起。我并不是真的想限定或思考那是什么，
what that is. You know, I'm not going to encourage something dangerous. I'm going to recognize, you know, an ego dissolution that's maybe leaning towards psychosis in a, in a way to help you. But that is the experience.
那是什么。你知道，我不会鼓励危险的事情。我会识别，你知道，一种可能倾向于精神病的自我瓦解，以一种帮助你的方式。但这就是体验。
I'm not encouraging it i make i'm validating it and then participating in it not absolutely i don't know this is that too open absolutely no no no no absolutely i think it's uh i think in the world we live now particularly there is such a closing down of of curiosity and and holding the tension of of not knowing um and of you know where if somebody asks you you know do you believe in this or not you know and it becomes like a binary do you believe in god yes or no you know this this kind of question. Do you, you know, do you believe what I'm saying to you? And as a therapist, we have to believe what our clients are telling us, right? We have to, we can't be kind of thinking that what they're telling us is a lie. But on the other hand,
我不是在鼓励它，我是在验证它，然后参与其中，不，绝对不是，我不知道这是否太开放了，绝对不是，不，不，不，绝对不是，我认为，嗯，我认为在我们现在生活的世界里，特别是，人们对好奇心和保持那种不知道的张力有一种封闭，嗯，而且，你知道，如果有人问你，你知道，你相信这个吗，或者不相信，你知道，它变成了一个二元对立，你相信上帝吗，是或否，你知道，这种问题。你，你知道，你相信我对你所说的话吗？作为治疗师，我们必须相信我们的客户告诉我们的话，对吧？我们必须，我们不能认为他们告诉我们的是谎言。但另一方面，
we're also thinking at the same time what does what does this mean and we need to find a way to explore with our clients the meaning of what they're telling us and whether that is that they've actually been to the woods that day and they've seen a fairy um you know or or that they've actually just broken up with their partner and or they're having problems at work, you know. You know, these kind of experiences with a fairy, say a fairy sighting, are we just going to dismiss this as psychosis or are we going to think about what that means to that person
我们同时也在思考这意味着什么，我们需要找到一种方法与我们的客户一起探索他们告诉我们的内容的含义，无论这是他们那天真的去了树林，看到了仙女，你知道，还是他们刚刚和伴侣分手，或者他们在工作中遇到问题，你知道。你知道，这些与仙女的经历，比如看到仙女，我们是要仅仅将其斥为精神病，还是我们要思考这对那个人意味着什么
without kind of becoming over-an and making a project um an interpretation of it um and just holding that open um i don't think there's anything problematic about that unless we you know obviously if that particular person has um problems you know is is um very unwell and they're having psychotic episodes and we're concerned about that person, then that's another matter and we have to think about that, right? It's coming back to what I said about risk and safety. But it may not be that. It may simply be that this person has had an incredible experience. They've had this numinous experience. They've seen something in the woods. They've seen this fairy in the woods it me it really has changed their life it's changed their whole reality and let's think about that wow what
而不至于变得过度分析，并对其进行投射，嗯，只是保持开放，嗯，我不认为这有什么问题，除非我们，你知道，显然如果那个人有，嗯，问题，你知道，是，嗯，非常不健康，他们有精神病发作，我们担心那个人，那么那是另一回事，我们必须考虑这一点，对吧？这回到了我所说的关于风险和安全的问题。但可能并非如此。可能仅仅是这个人有了一次不可思议的经历。他们有了这种神圣的体验。他们在树林里看到了什么。他们在树林里看到了这个仙女，它真的改变了他们的生活，它改变了他们的整个现实，让我们思考一下，哇，发生了什么
an incredible thing that happened to you you know um so yeah i think we have to hold all of all of those things open you know but the but the person i think but the other thing about that is that obviously clients can have a sneaking suspicion as well that the person is just saying yeah i believe you or oh how interesting you know or i validate your experience and and there's a sense of artifice about that right there's a lack of sincerity you know trust in the relationship has to be built it's not just validate your experience is a terrifying phrase that's gonna make me head for the door yeah so you know what i mean right that that that's kind of hard one isn't it
一件不可思议的事情发生在你身上，你知道，嗯，所以是的，我认为我们必须保持所有这些事情的开放，你知道，但那个人，我认为，但关于那一点的另一件事是，显然客户也会有一种隐秘的怀疑，认为那个人只是在说，是的，我相信你，或者哦，多有趣，你知道，或者我验证你的经历，这有一种虚伪的感觉，对吧，缺乏真诚，你知道，关系中的信任必须建立，不仅仅是验证你的经历，这是一个可怕的短语，会让我转身离开，是的，所以你知道我的意思，对吧，那，那是一种来之不易的东西，不是吗
that that's hard one from the therapist um and and that takes time so so yeah i think it can be taught or you think it can be taught? Or do you think we just look for students that know how to do it and then give them a language for it? I think, no, I think it can only come really, it can be taught a little bit, but it also through our own, obviously we really need to have our own therapy. That's the most, that's how we learn to be therapists, I think, through having our own experience of therapy. So that's how we learn to be therapists i think through having our own experiences of therapy so that's like number one through supervision super important
那，那是治疗师来之不易的，嗯，而且这需要时间，所以，所以是的，我认为它可以被教导，或者你认为它可以被教导？或者你认为我们只是寻找知道如何做到的学生，然后给他们一种语言？我认为，不，我认为它只能真正来自，它可以被教导一点，但它也通过我们自己的，显然我们真的需要有我们自己的治疗。这是最，这就是我们学习成为治疗师的方式，我认为，通过拥有我们自己的治疗经验。所以这就是我们学习成为治疗师的方式，我认为通过拥有我们自己的治疗经验，所以这就像第一点，通过督导，超级重要
number two and also through experience i guess in our own life experiences our own experiences maybe of um you know of synchronicity or the uncanny or weird stuff happening that cannot be explained through kind of material explanations and kind of accepting that um all of those things are are very important you know we're trying to you know perhaps writing down our own dreams you know the more we understand about ourselves the better right so that we can kind of but yeah i would say and but the most important thing is is relationship isn't it with with the person yeah yeah and you you talk about the kind of western esoteric magic influence and a lot of your work uh do you look at anthropology much you know well in yeah i mean in the book there's a there is a chapter in the book um where i'm looking at
第二点，也通过经验，我想，在我们自己的人生经历中，我们自己可能有的，嗯，你知道，共时性或离奇或奇怪的事情发生，这些不能通过物质解释来解释，并且接受这一点，嗯，所有这些事情都非常重要，你知道，我们正在尝试，你知道，也许写下我们自己的梦，你知道，我们对自己了解得越多越好，对吧，这样我们就可以，但是的，我会说，但最重要的事情是关系，不是吗，与那个人，是的，是的，你谈到了西方深奥魔法的影响，以及你工作中的很多内容，嗯，你经常看人类学吗，你知道，嗯，是的，我的意思是，在书中，有一章，在书中，嗯，我在看
these because i'm exploring um there's a chapter i can't remember chapter eight or nine where i'm talking about the evil eye yeah so there's quite a lot about because i wanted to think about aggression um and in in relation to the curse because as I was saying earlier when you were asking me about treatment how we work with the curse you know is and how how the person's identifying with the aggressive you know such an aggressive thing to be cursed or curse somebody it's a terrible thing you know putting pins in a voodoo doll you know it's awful making an image you know a poppet of somebody and you know and burning it or whatever you do you know it's it's nasty isn't it so there's a real aggression there so i wanted
这些，因为我正在探索，嗯，有一章，我不记得是第八章还是第九章，我在谈论邪眼，是的，所以有很多关于，因为我想思考攻击性，以及与诅咒的关系，因为正如我早些时候所说的，当你问我关于治疗的问题，我们如何处理诅咒，你知道，是，以及那个人如何认同这种攻击性，你知道，被诅咒或诅咒某人是一件非常有攻击性的事情，这是一件可怕的事情，你知道，在巫毒娃娃上插针，你知道，这很糟糕，制作一个形象，你知道，某人的玩偶，你知道，然后烧掉它，或者无论你做什么，你知道，这很恶心，不是吗，所以那里有一种真正的攻击性，所以我想要
to explore that um through a more kind of through anthropological research um So I was looking at that through examples in Ethiopia with the Buddha, B-U-D-A, the Buddha people and their relationship with another tribe there, which, and there's a lot of conflict and essentially it's really, another tribe there, and there's a lot of conflict. And essentially, it turned out to be a really helpful example of how to think about aggression and how that relates to the supernatural. Okay, so how that relates to agency. Because if you think about, because it seemed to me, anyway, looking at this anthropological research of the Buddha people, that the hyena became a very, was a symbol, again, there's the word symbol, a representative or a carrier of the curse, right?
去探索那个，嗯，通过一种更，通过人类学研究，所以我通过埃塞俄比亚的布达（Buda）人的例子来看待那个，B-U-D-A，布达人以及他们与那里另一个部落的关系，这，而且有很多冲突，本质上它确实是，另一个部落，而且有很多冲突。本质上，它成为了一个非常有帮助的例子，说明如何思考攻击性以及它如何与超自然现象相关联。好的，那么它如何与能动性相关联。因为如果你思考，因为在我看来，无论如何，看着这些关于布达人的人类学研究，鬣狗成为了一个非常，又是那个词，符号，一个代表或诅咒的载体，对吧？
So the hyena embodied all that was evil and was like that could cause harm um and probably a scary thing there's probably you know some evolutionary biological reasons why you absolutely that's dying is going to bring bad stuff to the village it's going to eat your baby here absolutely so but there's this kind of but but the Buddha people also have a very strong relationship to the supernatural in terms of their capacity to shapeshift. So they themselves can actually ride these hyenas and to shapeshift themselves and they're very connected to the spirit world this other um tribe which i can't remember the name of they were very threatened by the buddha people um and because of their their putative supernatural powers right so but the but the buddha people were very much a disenfranchised population, right?
所以鬣狗体现了所有邪恶的东西，就像它可能造成伤害，嗯，而且可能是一件可怕的事情，可能有一些进化生物学的原因，为什么你绝对，那快要死了会给村庄带来坏事，它会吃掉你的婴儿，这里绝对是，所以，但有这种，但布达人与超自然现象也有很强的关系，就他们变形的能力而言。所以他们自己实际上可以骑这些鬣狗，并让自己变形，他们与精神世界联系非常紧密，这个另一个，嗯，部落，我不记得名字了，他们非常受到布达人的威胁，嗯，因为他们所谓的超自然力量，对吧，所以，但布达人很大程度上是一个被剥夺权利的群体，对吧？
They were disadvantaged compared to the other tribe, whose name, again, I can't recall. So they were very dominated by this other group of people, right? So it was something along the lines of colonialism. You might look at it in those terms. And their means of pushing back against that was through their capacity to shapeshift to identify with the aggressive aspects of the curse and also we see this with and again this is in the book I thought Emma Wilby who's a historian in the UK. Her book is just brilliant, really helpful,
与另一个部落相比，他们处于劣势，那个部落的名字，我同样记不起来了。所以他们非常受到这另一群人的支配，对吧？所以这有点类似于殖民主义。你可能会用这些术语来看待它。他们反击这种支配的方式是通过他们变形的能力，去认同诅咒的攻击性方面，我们也看到了这一点，而且这又是在书中，我想艾玛·威尔比（Emma Wilby），她是英国的一位历史学家。她的书简直太棒了，非常有帮助，
because it was thinking about how, very much in terms of witchcraft and the witch trials in the UK, how it's always seen as taboo for the witches to actually genuinely be cursing, right? To actually genuinely be cursing, right? To actually genuinely be doing that, to using kind of quote-unquote black magic, right? Because, and she says that it's become taboo because there's something uncomfortable about women's aggression.
因为它是在思考，非常就巫术和英国的猎巫审判而言，为什么巫师实际上真的在诅咒总是被视为禁忌，对吧？实际上真的在诅咒，对吧？实际上真的在做那件事，使用所谓的黑魔法，对吧？因为，她说它之所以成为禁忌，是因为女性的攻击性有一些令人不舒服的地方。
So men don't like the fact that these, you know, so like, because of course these these women the width of the witches were forced to confess to things that they didn't do yes absolutely but on the other hand what she's saying yeah okay but why is it still taboo though to think about the fact they might have done that and that kind of still exists around today so there's something about that that aggression so but that aggression can be powerful and it and so you can get really that that can be a source of agency and i think it was and if you look at again at those that in in the cases of witchcraft they did they we can perhaps you know obviously i don't know but i'm imagining that that could have been a source of agency right a source of empowerment and that can be also for our our clients as well if they
所以男人不喜欢这个事实，你知道，所以，就像，因为当然这些女性，这些巫师被迫承认她们没有做过的事情，是的，绝对是，但另一方面，她所说的是，是的，好吧，但为什么思考她们可能真的做过那件事仍然是禁忌呢，而且那种情况在今天仍然存在，所以关于那种攻击性有一些东西，但那种攻击性可以是强大的，它，所以你可以得到，那可以成为能动性的来源，我认为它是，如果你再看那些，在巫术的案例中，他们确实，我们也许可以，显然我不知道，但我设想那可能是一个能动性的来源，对吧，一个赋权的来源，这对我们的客户来说也可以是这样，如果他们
can find a vehicle to express all of the rage that they feel about their trauma whether it's towards the therapist with this towards whether it's through other means however they do that that there's something very important about that and uh it's exploring that in the therapy so yeah well i mean a lot of the the things that like i hear you say in the book where you're talking about um they're they're more the kind of cultural and sociological thing of like we take our anger um and we put it in a magical belief system or a series of hierarchies and rules and order or some some sort of you know system that we have to inhabit and that a lot of therapy is pulling it back and saying no you you are angry you do have this agency and pulling it back into the individual out of the system
能找到一种载体来表达他们对创伤所感受到的所有愤怒，无论是对治疗师，还是通过其他方式，无论他们如何做，这其中有一些非常重要的事情，嗯，在治疗中探索这一点，所以是的，好吧，我的意思是，我在书中听到你说的很多事情，你谈论的是，嗯，它们更多的是一种文化和社会学的东西，比如我们把我们的愤怒，我们把它放入一个魔法信仰系统或一系列等级制度、规则和秩序中，或者某种，你知道，我们必须居住的系统，而很多治疗是把它拉回来，说不，你，你很愤怒，你确实有这种能动性，并把它从系统中拉回到个人身上
you know yeah by reflecting on it um i was wondering more when i said anthropology about like the kind of evolutionarily or biological you know precedent for for some of these things um like you know looking at um the neolithic you know religion or something where a lot of these things i think were more embodied you know it's not like we look at it as um we look at it as like the people who say like oh well, well, you shouldn't think that way or something. It's like, no, we, we do think that way. You know, we did for a long time. We now have the ability to think multiple different ways, but sometimes we have to go
你知道，是的，通过反思它，嗯，当我提到人类学时，我更多地是在想，比如，这些事情的进化或生物学先例，你知道，比如，你知道，看着新石器时代的宗教或类似的东西，我认为其中很多事情更具具身性，你知道，并不是我们把它看作，嗯，我们把它看作，比如那些说，哦，好吧，你不应该那样想之类的人。就像，不，我们，我们确实那样想。你知道，我们很长一段时间都是这样。我们现在有能力以多种不同的方式思考，但有时我们必须回到
back into the old way in order to heal the process because that's where the thing problem was coming from. Like I do a lot of complex PTSD and especially dissociative disorders. And so a ton of what I'm trying to explain there is like, you know, we've made these processes unconscious because our brainstem is handling them for us, basically. So that intuition is coming from the same place as our trauma response, because they're all just ways that we've learned to basically offload, you know, passively all of this other processing to something else. And so when I say,
旧的方式，以便治愈这个过程，因为问题就是从那里产生的。比如我做很多复杂性创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），特别是解离性障碍。所以我在那里试图解释的很多东西是，你知道，我们已经让这些过程变得无意识，因为我们的脑干基本上在为我们处理它们。所以那种直觉来自与我们创伤反应相同的地方，因为它们都只是我们学会基本上卸载，你知道，被动地将所有这些其他处理过程转移到别处的方式。所以当我说，
you know, my head hurts, it feels like a curse, like this is just happening to me, but it's my head. You know, if I really do somatic work and I feel the tension and I feel what I'm doing and my emotional response, you know, I can go back and take over that old thought process that was just offloaded to when I see a man in a red sweater every morning, when I go to work, this activates this old trauma and my body gets tight. And this is what I have to do with these emotions. And I don't have any control of it. This is just something that my body does, you know, in a, in a paleolithic society or something, you know, when we're semi-conscious or coming into consciousness, we're unloading
你知道，我的头很痛，感觉就像一个诅咒，就像这只是发生在我身上，但这是我的头。你知道，如果我真的做躯体工作，我感觉到紧张，我感觉到我在做什么以及我的情绪反应，你知道，我可以回去接管那个被卸载的旧思维过程，当我每天早上上班时看到一个穿红毛衣的男人，这激活了这个旧的创伤，我的身体变得紧绷。这就是我必须用这些情绪做的事情。我对此没有任何控制权。这只是我的身体所做的事情，你知道，在，在旧石器时代的社会或类似的地方，你知道，当我们半清醒或进入意识时，我们正在卸载
all of this information into the environment. You know, the river is alive. The rain cloud is thinking for me, it's telling me that I need to go to this you know it was this older way of being and if you work with psychosis or something you see that happening again and it and and like yeah you're not functional it's not the goal isn't to be there but kind of being in that experience where a lot of our um cognition is offloaded to the environment and embodied and we're thinking very magically you know i don't think it's does that making sense i mean i don't mean to be far in the woods with your idea like i think the way that it's taught in school by the cbt people when you learn that is that there was a group of cavemen that was like we don't have science yet and so what we need to do is think that there's a cloud that if we light this meat on fire is going to bring rain which wasn't it it was
所有这些信息到环境中。你知道，河流是活的。雨云在为我思考，它在告诉我我需要去这个，你知道，这是一种更古老的生存方式，如果你处理精神病或类似的东西，你会看到这种情况再次发生，而且，而且，是的，你没有功能，目标不是在那里，但那种处于那种体验中，我们很多，嗯，认知被卸载到环境中并具身化，我们思考得非常神奇，你知道，我不认为，这有意义吗，我的意思是，我不是想在你的想法中走得太远，就像我认为CBT（认知行为疗法）的人在学校里教导它的方式是，有一群穴居人，他们就像，我们还没有科学，所以我们需要做的是认为有一朵云，如果我们把这块肉点火，就会带来雨，这并不是，它是
a huge relationship with the environment where it was thinking for me i see this this means this and a lot of your work it kind of reminds me of that sort of early thing of put part of your consciousness back in your environment do a ritual and then bring it back into your own head and then have that that i don't know i've talked too much i apologize no no no i'm thinking yeah i mean i think that uh from that sort of anthropological lens i think i'm i say again in there in there in the book about uh you know james fraser's work in the golden valve and how that's problematic because we have this kind of idea of animistic consciousness first, then magical as part of magical consciousness, going through to religious consciousness, and then through to science, which is the apex, you know, it's the pinnacle of what we can achieve,
一种与环境的巨大关系，在那里它在为我思考，我看到这个，这意味着这个，而你的很多工作，它有点让我想起那种早期的东西，把你的部分意识放回你的环境中，做一个仪式，然后把它带回你自己的头脑中，然后有那个，我不知道，我说得太多了，我道歉，不，不，我正在思考，是的，我的意思是，我认为，从那种人类学视角来看，我认为我再次在书中提到，关于，你知道，詹姆斯·弗雷泽（James Frazer）在《金枝》（The Golden Bough）中的工作，以及为什么那是有问题的，因为我们有这种关于万物有灵论意识优先，然后是作为魔法意识一部分的魔法，经历到宗教意识，然后到科学，这是顶点，你知道，这是我们能达到的巅峰，
and isn't it amazing what we've done and sort of through this progressive cycle. And in that, along the way, we've kind of repressed so much of that early way of being in the world, you know, through that animism and through having that relationship with, as you say, with nature through the river and the trees so that we can actually, so if you do see a fairy in the woods, it's going to be obviously a lot more normal in those terms. And I think, you know, I think the more attuned we become to those kind of ways of being in the world, you know, so if we do take a walk in the woods on our own, for example, maybe it's dusk or and we look at a tree, but it kind of looked alive, you know, and it's that sort of, you know,
而且我们所做的事情真是太神奇了，通过这种进步的循环。而在那过程中，我们已经压抑了太多那种早期在世界上生存的方式，你知道，通过那种万物有灵论，通过与，正如你所说的，与自然通过河流和树木建立那种关系，这样我们实际上可以，所以如果你确实在树林里看到一个仙女，用这些术语来说，那显然会正常得多。而且我认为，你知道，我认为我们对那种在世界上生存的方式变得越协调，你知道，所以如果我们确实独自在树林里散步，例如，也许是黄昏，或者我们看着一棵树，但它看起来有点活，你知道，而且那是那种，你知道，
those liminal areas of reality, which are so important and that we just dismiss through this kind of materialistic way of being in the world as if, you know, that's the kind of the best way to be. And it becomes very, very boring and reductive. And I think that's, I also mentioned in the book about this, you know, this artist like Austin Osmond Spare, who talks about the, you know,
那些现实的阈限区域，它们非常重要，而我们只是通过这种物质主义的生存方式将其斥为，你知道，好像，那是最好的生存方式。它变得非常，非常无聊和还原论。而且我认为那是，我也在书中提到了这个，你知道，这个艺术家，像奥斯汀·奥斯曼·斯佩尔（Austin Osman Spare），他谈论，你知道，
going back and finding this simplicity, simplicity you know he really reveres simplicity so he kind of reverses the evolutionary cycle so he's saying we should go back kind of to the simplicity of the amoeba right kind of draw upon that um and you know there's also obviously the the the child if you, the child is compared in this kind of Fraser's terms in the Golden Bower or in Freud's terms also as this kind of, and there's this sort of developmental kind of line, if you like. But the child is compared to this animistic animistic period do you see what i mean so they were just kind of children they didn't really know what they were doing they were seeing fairies in the trees you know uh look at those silly people but actually you know what spares spare was saying is you know that's that kind of the simplicity of the child is what we should
回去寻找这种简单，简单，你知道，他非常崇敬简单，所以他有点逆转了进化循环，所以他说我们应该回到，比如阿米巴原虫的简单，对吧，从那里汲取，嗯，而且，你知道，显然还有，嗯，孩子，如果你，孩子在这种弗雷泽的术语中，在《金枝》中，或者在弗洛伊德的术语中，也被比较为这种，而且有一种发展路线，如果你愿意的话。但孩子被比作这个万物有灵论时期，你明白我的意思吗，所以他们只是孩子，他们真的不知道自己在做什么，他们在树上看到仙女，你知道，嗯，看看那些愚蠢的人，但实际上，你知道，斯佩尔所说的是，你知道，那种孩子的简单正是我们应该
kind of be aiming for you know rather than kind of just dressing it up in all's that kind of the simplicity of the child is what we should kind of be aiming for, you know, rather than kind of just dressing it up in all of this kind of nonsense, really. And so if you and if you look at for if you look at Freud's model of repression, you know, it's all about how we've repressed our, our sexual aggressive drives, right? And we kind of they can't be incorporated into the ego fair enough absolutely there is that going on but and he's kind of pointing at that's the reason why you have this weird stuff going on because it's down to this sort of repression but actually what i'm saying in the book is like yeah but you've also repressed this animistic consciousness
某种程度上应该瞄准的，你知道，而不是仅仅把它包装在所有这些，那种孩子的简单正是我们应该某种程度上应该瞄准的，你知道，而不是仅仅把它包装在所有这些废话中，真的。所以如果你，如果你看弗洛伊德的压抑模型，你知道，这完全是关于我们如何压抑了我们的，我们的性攻击驱动力，对吧？而且我们，它们不能被纳入自我，公平地说，绝对是，那确实在发生，但，而且他有点指出，这就是为什么你有这种奇怪的事情发生，因为它是归结于这种压抑，但实际上我在书中说的是，是的，但你也压抑了这种万物有灵论意识
and that's why i mean freud writes in the essay the uncanny about his own uncanny experiences and he's wondering why he's having them is well you know i think that's that's a good reason why right because you're kind of saying that there's that they're just part of this this this part of history that's dead but you can't you can't kill that off as you're saying in the depths of the psyche in the depths of the brainstem it's it's still there you know well i think freud too you know said that like he wants to reduce everything down to sexuality because he's saying that everything that the first impulse that we have evolutionarily is
这就是为什么，我的意思是，弗洛伊德在《恐怖谷》（The Uncanny）一文中写到了他自己离奇的经历，他想知道为什么他会有这些经历，嗯，你知道，我认为那是一个很好的理由，对吧，因为你有点在说，它们只是这段历史的一部分，这段历史已经死了，但你不能，你不能扼杀它，正如你所说的，在心灵的深处，在脑干的深处，它仍然在那里，你知道，嗯，我认为弗洛伊德也，你知道，说他想把一切都还原为性，因为他在说，我们进化上拥有的第一个冲动是
going to be you know mate selection and you know the the most dominant thing passes on its genes or whatever but we have multiple levels of the brain other than natural selection that were designed to solve other problems you know we it didn't just start with that and then get bigger and bigger and bigger and better at it there's actually three or you know depending on how you want to sort them, multiple competing drives, like in consciousness, of which sexuality is only one. Yes. So go on, go on.
将会是，你知道，配偶选择，你知道，最占优势的东西传递它的基因，或者其他什么，但我们有除了自然选择之外的多个大脑层次，它们旨在解决其他问题，你知道，我们，它不仅仅是从那个开始，然后变得越来越大，越来越好，实际上有三个，或者，取决于你想如何分类它们，多个竞争的驱动力，比如在意识中，性只是其中之一。是的。所以继续，继续。
No, that's it. Just to reduce it down to that is, you know, how do you do that? Yes. And I think that's where the, you know, the work of Yak Pansip comes in, doesn't it? And Mark Solms, I know, the psychoanalyst who's re-translated the the collected works of freud has kind of um incorporated that into into the the inter-psychoanalysis so i think that's a that's a really helpful update as well so that you've got those um it's not only about those two you know it's not about the life and death instinct it's also about the it's also about our curiosity our seeking and our fear and our panic and
不，就是这样。仅仅把它还原为那个，是，你知道，你怎么能那样做？是的。而且我认为这就是，你知道，雅克·潘克塞普（Jaak Panksepp）的工作发挥作用的地方，不是吗？还有马克·索姆斯（Mark Solms），我知道，那位重新翻译了弗洛伊德全集的精神分析学家，已经将那种，嗯，纳入了精神分析中，所以我认为那也是一个非常有帮助的更新，所以你有那些，嗯，它不仅仅是关于那两个，你知道，它不是关于生与死的本能，它也是关于，它也是关于我们的好奇心，我们的寻求，以及我们的恐惧和我们的恐慌，以及
all of that and and also that's you know bringing back to mythology again you know coming back to the curse position you know if you think about pan you know and the kind of the panic that pan sort of causes, but it's by being in touch with our internal pan, if you like, which can really help us to get in touch with those more animistic, primitive parts of ourselves, right, which can be really helpful for healing. Yeah, and the only way i think to be um to heal them and to be present with them is to quit thinking about them you know metaphor is still thinking it's still me getting distance between this thing and me that's right but it
所有这些，而且，而且那也是，你知道，再次回到神话，你知道，回到诅咒的位置，你知道，如果你思考潘（Pan），以及潘那种引起的恐慌，但正是通过与我们内在的潘接触，如果你愿意的话，这真的可以帮助我们与我们自己那些更具万物有灵论、原始的部分接触，对吧，这对于治愈真的非常有帮助。是的，而且我认为治愈它们并与它们同在的唯一方法是停止思考它们，你知道，隐喻仍然是思考，它仍然是我在这个事物和我之间制造距离，那是对的，但它
isn't real in this other way that's threatening and it really has to be something that you um that you go back into and just feel um who knows where it comes from i'm not pretending to know but you do have to feel it in order to go through it. Yes. And I think that's the great value of, you know, because I really value the weird, you know, I really value the uncanny of, you know, these kind of strange experiences that we cannot explain. You these are sources of mystery you know um and like arthur macken the the writer says you know well everything ends in mystery that's what's written on his grave you know and i just love that because it's all about that these things are offerings aren't they they're windows into that that kind of mysterious world i mean and we
在另一种威胁性的方式中并不真实，它真的必须是你，嗯，你回去并只是感受的东西，谁知道它来自哪里，我不是假装知道，但你确实必须感受它才能经历它。是的。而且我认为那是，你知道，巨大的价值，因为我真的很看重奇怪的东西，你知道，我真的很看重离奇的东西，你知道，这些我们无法解释的奇怪经历。你，这些是神秘的来源，你知道，嗯，就像亚瑟·梅琴（Arthur Machen），那位作家说，你知道，嗯，一切都以神秘告终，这就是写在他墓碑上的话，你知道，我真的很喜欢那个，因为这完全是关于这些东西是祭品，不是吗，它们是通往那种神秘世界的窗口，我的意思是，而且我们
see this with writers as well you know we see that you know when i was a child i remember the lion the witch in the wardrobe you know this kind of these portals into into other worlds we need to have that kind of um connection with it but that doesn't come through um a contrived means of finding it kind of just happens through kind of unpredictable strange experiences a lot of the time and all but also importantly I recently wrote was writing a short essay on this about this called about relational presence because we can feel with we often have these kind of experiences where like you and i are now we when we're
在作家身上也看到了这一点，你知道，我们看到，你知道，当我还是个孩子的时候，我记得《纳尼亚传奇：狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》（The Lion, the Witch and the Wardrobe），你知道，这些通往其他世界的门户，我们需要有那种，嗯，与它的联系，但这并不是通过，嗯，一种人为的寻找方式，它通常只是通过不可预测的奇怪经历而发生，而且，但同样重要的是，我最近写了一篇关于这个的短文，关于关系存在，因为我们可以感受到，我们经常有这些经历，比如你和我现在，我们，当我们
speaking to other people or when we're with people that are close to us we have um because with affect is so important the emotions are so so important for having for experiences of the supernatural or spiritual they're often in communion with other people or with animals or with plants or with nature that's that these are all really really important for healing aren't they getting off and also getting out of this kind of um getting off the phone you know and getting out into the world and allowing ourselves to dream and experience states of reverie you know and daydreaming rather than, like you're saying, just this kind of cognitive prison
与其他人交谈时，或者当我们与我们亲近的人在一起时，我们有，嗯，因为情感是如此重要，情绪对于拥有超自然或精神体验是如此，如此重要，它们通常是与其他人，或与动物，或与植物，或与自然交流，这就是，这些对于治愈都非常非常重要，不是吗，摆脱，而且还要走出这种，嗯，放下手机，你知道，走进世界，允许我们做梦和体验沉思的状态，你知道，白日梦，而不是，像你所说的，只是这种认知监狱
that we can easily get stuck in. You can't think your way out of a myth. I mean, I think the overly interpretive mythographers are the ones that I'm a little suspicious of. The ones who realize that we are part of it are a little bit more interesting. Yes, yes, it's kind of getting away from this as if mentality isn't it is that what you're saying is there anything else that that you want to um kind of touch on from the the the book and i think we gave people probably a pretty good overview of what you know where to get going with
我们很容易陷入其中。你无法通过思考走出神话。我的意思是，我认为过度解释的神话学家是我有点怀疑的人。那些意识到我们是它的一部分的人稍微有趣一点。是的，是的，这有点远离这种好像的心态，不是吗，这就是你所说的，还有什么其他你想要，嗯，触及的，从书中，而且我认为我们可能给了人们一个相当好的概述，关于你知道，从哪里开始
it um or your other work you know yeah well not really i guess what i'm trying to think about what i've been trying to think about for a while is how we is like how in the modern world how we can incorporate you know a theory of mind which incorporates these realities you know you have um so that it doesn't become reductive it doesn't become as if so that we can um in in psychotherapy particularly because that's obviously our profession how we can do that um and i guess we have all sorts of interesting sort of ontologies now don't we we'd like things like panpsychism and and um all kinds of um all kinds of other ways of seeing reality um which you may or may not agree with but i think it seems that things are opening up quite a lot aren't they
它，嗯，或者你的其他工作，你知道，是的，好吧，并不是真的，我想我一直在试图思考的是，我们是如何，就像在现代世界中，我们如何能够整合，你知道，一种包含这些现实的心智理论，你知道，你有，嗯，这样它就不会变得还原论，它不会变得好像，这样我们就可以，在心理治疗中，特别是，因为那显然是我们的职业，我们如何能够做到这一点，嗯，而且我想我们现在有各种各样有趣的本体论，不是吗，我们喜欢像泛灵论这样的东西，以及，嗯，各种各样，嗯，各种其他看待现实的方式，嗯，你可能同意也可能不同意，但我认为事情似乎正在开放很多，不是吗
um all of the different kind of subcultures if we call them that like within our culture um shamanism um paganism etc etc that we can lots of interest in witchcraft in tarot and um so i think it's it's a very very exciting time um so yeah how i suppose when we're thinking about the mind how can we think about spirit you know how do we you know are entities part of our mind or i mean it's the eternal question isn't it or are they or are they did they have their own agency you know and i think we can we can have both you know i think that we can have the entities which in our in our in our minds right but we also have entities which have their own agencies that we can't apprehend and that we don't know. And sometimes that can be uncomfortable for people to think about, I think.
嗯，所有不同种类的亚文化，如果我们称它们为那样，在我们的文化中，萨满教，异教等，等等，我们可以有很多对巫术、塔罗牌的兴趣，以及，嗯，所以我认为这是一个非常，非常令人兴奋的时代，嗯，所以是的，我假设当我们思考心智时，我们如何思考精神，你知道，我们如何，你知道，实体是我们心智的一部分吗，或者我的意思是，这是一个永恒的问题，不是吗，或者它们，或者它们，它们有它们自己的能动性吗，你知道，而且我认为我们可以，我们可以两者兼有，你知道，我认为我们可以有在我们心智中的实体，对吧，但我们也有拥有它们自己能动性的实体，我们无法理解，而且我们不知道。而且有时这对人们来说可能是不舒服的，我想。
Yeah, very, very uncomfortable because it's disembodying. It's taking away the certainty that, I mean, I think a lot of therapy at the root is making people be, one, admit, and then two, become more comfortable with the fact that we have very little control. And a lot of the symptoms are trying to pretend that we have more control than we do yeah or something if you ever looked at uh like uh that idea of the post-secular sacred david tacy writes about it a lot um but it comes from you there young had this idea that they were kind of going to be these three epics that earlier you know there was this you know spiritual literalism that the myth the the magic was just real and that you participate in it and and then that was overthrown for this kind of age of modernist science where the only thing that was
是的，非常，非常不舒服，因为它让人脱离身体。它剥夺了确定性，我的意思是，我认为很多治疗在根源上是让人，第一，承认，然后第二，变得更适应我们几乎没有控制权的事实。而很多症状是试图假装我们比实际拥有更多的控制权，是的，或者类似的东西，如果你曾经看过，嗯，像，嗯，那种后世俗神圣的想法，大卫·塔西（David Tacey）写了很多关于它的东西，但它来自你，荣格有这个想法，即会有这三个时代，早些时候，你知道，有这种，你知道，精神字面主义，神话，魔法只是真实的，你参与其中，然后那被推翻，为了这种现代主义科学时代，其中唯一的东西是
real was the objective and the subjective was kind of gone and that eventually that would fall apart because what we were observing was going to become so vast and complicated that we couldn't completely understand it objective anyway and then there would be this what he what tacy says is a post-secular sacred where people say okay but quantum physics you know but you know um these huge abstract systems are also something that we don't really understand so there is a it's useful to have sort of a metaphorical definition of god it's useful to bring back some of these ideas and um to have a little bit more kind of poetry and subjective experience
现实是客观的，而主观性在某种程度上已经消失了，最终这会分崩离析，因为我们所观察到的事物将变得如此广阔和复杂，以至于我们无法完全以客观的方式去理解它。然后就会出现塔西（Tacey）所说的“后世俗神圣”，人们会说，好吧，但是量子物理学，你知道，这些巨大的抽象系统也是我们并不真正理解的东西。因此，拥有某种隐喻性的上帝定义是有用的，重新引入其中一些想法，并拥有更多一点的诗意和主观体验也是有用的。
which yeah yeah yeah i think i think there is a yeah i don't know David Lacey's work at all but Tacey that's it sorry David Tacey yeah um I don't know his work but I think there is that tendency isn't it um and which um we can easily fall into to kind of we need to sort of again there's that word validate sort of validate our experience by oh look in quantum physics you have this you know and this is what they they you know it's kind of it's proven and then you end up all you end up doing is undermining your own kind of experience or your own ontology you know and i think that that that's kind of you know why why do you always have to seek something else? And I think, you know, say, for example, the psychoanalyst Adam Phillips, his writing is great.
是的，是的，是的，我想，我想确实有这种倾向，不是吗？我们很容易陷入这种境地，我们需要再次——那个词是“验证”——通过“看，在量子物理学中你有这个”来验证我们的经验，这就像是“被证明了”。然后你最终所做的只是削弱了你自己的经验或你自己的本体论。你知道，我认为这就是为什么你总是必须寻求其他东西的原因？我认为，例如，精神分析学家亚当·菲利普斯（Adam Phillips），他的作品就很棒。
And he sees psychoanalysis as a form of art, you know, as a kind of poetry. And he's not kind of looking for it to be any more than that. But there's something about that poetry and that art that heals. Do you see what I mean? So I think if we can kind of just settle a bit with what we have and kind of explore that and be okay with that, we don't always kind of need to validate it with this kind of external other, you know, that always knows better. It's very Lacanian, isn't it? This other that knows more than us you know uh yeah do you ever you ever build a computer
他将精神分析视为一种艺术形式，一种诗歌。他并不指望它成为别的东西。但那种诗歌和艺术中确实有一些治愈的东西。你明白我的意思吗？所以我认为，如果我们能对我们所拥有的东西感到满足，去探索它并接受它，我们就不总是需要用那种总是自以为是的外部“他者”来验证它。这非常拉康（Lacanian），不是吗？这个比我们知道得更多的“他者”。你有没有组装过电脑？
or uh anything in the you know or probably of the age where that was a possibility i would be completely useless at that no i haven't i i very much like synthesizers um and messing around with like you know that kind of knob twiddling as it were you know just like but the actual you know the the understanding what's under the hood i wouldn't have a faintest idea i'm afraid yeah well there's some like uh i was you know old enough to actually that your computer came in several boxes and you put it together but that like the um of when I used to be an EMDR clinician, now I do primarily brain spotting and ETT. But one of the models of the same idea of consciousness I use for people who have that language is like, you know, you have your CPU, which is the central process. I know what that is. Yeah.
或者任何类似的东西？你可能处于那个时代，这是一种可能性。我在这方面完全没用，不，我没有。我非常喜欢合成器，喜欢摆弄那些旋钮之类的东西。但对于引擎盖下到底是什么，我恐怕一点头绪都没有。是的，好吧，我年纪够大，经历过电脑是分几个盒子装的，你需要自己组装。但我以前做EMDR临床医生时，现在我主要做脑点疗法（Brainspotting）和ETT。但我用来向人们解释意识模型的一种方式是，你有你的CPU，即中央处理器。我知道那是什么。是的。
Yeah. And it's really good at doing any kind of random calculation. So it can do a lot of very different things. You open a Word document, you open a video, you open a web browser, and then you have your GPU, which is able to do calculations really quickly that just have a couple numbers different, but millions of those incredibly quickly. So if you want to see the light reflecting off a gun and a first person shooter or physics, water moving, where, you know, it's doing a spreadsheet of problems incredibly fast, but it's not flexible. You know, the CPU offloads all that to it. And that's kind of getting deeper into the brainstem, you know, where you've got this thing that has
是的。它非常擅长进行任何随机计算。所以它可以做很多非常不同的事情。你打开一个Word文档，打开一个视频，打开一个网页浏览器。然后你有你的GPU，它能够非常快速地进行计算，这些计算只是数字上有几个不同，但有数百万个这样的计算。所以如果你想在第一人称射击游戏中看到光线从枪上反射，或者物理效果、水流，它在极快地处理电子表格问题，但它不灵活。你知道，CPU把所有这些都卸载给它。这有点像深入到脑干，你知道，你有这个东西，它已经
just learned. I'm not going to think about men make me uncomfortable because dad and this and all these compounding associations. So that when I'm around the situation, my back does that, you know, I'm not thinking about that. I'm just in my noticing triggers, they're happening. And it's going, I could, you know, drop down into that level of consciousness and think about it, if I was willing to turn, you know, the CPU off. And yeah, and the further down you go, the weirder it gets. I mean, now you have computers with these, you know, AI chips, essentially, where they're doing so much, you knowreferencing a lot of these like LLMs and generating models have these vectors where they're pinging so many data sets that there's no record of what they actually did. Like we can see what they did, but we don't know. We can't like, I can go through the GPU and say, okay, there's a bug. The background didn't render. So let me go through 10 spreadsheets in an hour.
学会了。我不会去想男人让我感到不舒服，因为父亲和所有这些复合的联想。所以当我在那种情况下，我的背部会有反应，你知道，我并没有在想那个。我只是在注意到触发因素，它们正在发生。我可以降到那个意识层面去思考它，如果我愿意关闭CPU的话。是的，你走得越深，它就越奇怪。我的意思是，现在你有这些AI芯片的电脑，本质上它们在做很多事情。引用很多像LLM（大语言模型）和生成模型，它们有向量，它们在ping这么多数据集，以至于没有记录它们到底做了什么。就像我们可以看到它们做了什么，但我们不知道。我不能像遍历GPU那样说，好吧，有一个错误。背景没有渲染。所以让我花一小时检查10个电子表格。
I can find what was wrong with an LLM. It tells you something and you don't know why I told you that no one knows there's no record it's a black box you know and so like those are the kind of levels of consciousness for me is it's like eventually you do get into this black box thing where you know you know during brain spawning a ton of times people feel like well i didn't know what this yeah this is the incident well this other thing is familiar and it's terrifying and it's deeper than the incident but what is it and then later they're oh this was fourth grade or something you know when you process it and then they get to these places that just feel disembodying and terrifying like they're like this isn't me like i don't understand what this is and you know sometimes
我可以在LLM中找到错误所在。它告诉你一些事情，而你不知道它为什么告诉你，没人知道，没有记录，这是一个黑匣子。所以对我来说，这些就是意识的层面。最终你确实会进入这个黑匣子，你知道，在脑点疗法期间，人们很多次觉得“我不知道这是什么，这是事件，好吧，这其他东西很熟悉，而且很可怕，它比事件本身更深，但它是什么？”然后后来他们意识到“哦，这是四年级时发生的事”，当你处理它时，他们会到达那些感觉脱离身体且可怕的地方，就像“这不是我，我不明白这是什么”。你知道，有时
people have a kind of poetic understanding of like oh this is how mom felt when i was in the womb you know she was afraid like this isn't even my emotion this is what i felt when I was in the womb. You know, she was afraid. Like, this isn't even my emotion. This is what I was told to feel as I was growing up. And, you know, of course, you could never prove that. You know, no one could ever come in and say, well, yeah, epigenetics works this way. Like, there's no way to study this. But it still, I think, is valid if people are getting better
人们有一种诗意的理解，比如“哦，这就是我在子宫里时妈妈的感觉，她很害怕，这甚至不是我的情绪，这是我在子宫里时的感觉。”你知道，她很害怕。这甚至不是我的情绪。这是我在成长过程中被告知要感受的东西。当然，你永远无法证明这一点。没有人能走过来说，好吧，表观遗传学就是这样运作的。没有办法研究这个。但我认为，如果人们正在好转，并且获得了一些可能不是智力知识的自我知识，这仍然是有效的。
and having some kind of self-knowledge that maybe is not intellectual knowledge. You know, I don't't know the professions are afraid of that post the 80s and margaret and thatcher margaret thatcher and reagan come in and everything has turned into this kind of objective metric in health care and it is very much at war i think with good trauma therapy in a way that you know we're still having that fight yes yes no i mean and again i was thinking about the intergenerational aspects as you as you were speaking about the cpu and just like and also the cpu becoming a you know kind of representing the the high levels of dysregulation that can happen in trauma as well as the person gets out of their window of tolerance you know their cpus are 90 or whatever
你知道，我不知道专业人士是否害怕80年代之后，玛格丽特·撒切尔和里根上台后，一切都变成了医疗保健中的这种客观指标，我认为这在某种程度上与良好的创伤治疗是冲突的，我们仍然在进行那场斗争。是的，是的，我的意思是，当我听到你谈论CPU时，我再次想到了代际方面，以及CPU成为一种代表创伤中可能发生的高水平失调，当人超出他们的承受窗口时，你知道他们的CPU是90%还是其他什么。
you know um but that there's something quite terrifying about that that sort of erasure of the mechanisms that lead to something um there's something really frightening about that actually and that that right kind of like makes me think about the unconscious you know and the layers and the layers and the kind of the depths of it that we just don't know about you know yeah and i'm not a techno utopian that thinks we're going to download our brain onto a computer and live on a server or something that just isn't uh any it didn't strike me at all but i think that the i think that the uh the metaphor there is kind of useful and just understanding how information is processed. Yeah,
你知道，但那种导致某事的机制的抹除确实有些相当可怕。实际上，这真的很令人恐惧。这让我想到了潜意识，你知道，那些层层叠叠的深度，我们只是不知道。是的，我不是一个认为我们会把大脑下载到电脑上并生活在服务器上的技术乌托邦主义者，那根本不是。这对我来说一点也不吸引人，但我认为其中的隐喻在理解信息是如何处理方面是有用的。是的。
absolutely. Well, is the book, the beginning of, you know, a greater model, you know, as the next, you know,
绝对。那么，这本书是某种更大模型的开始吗，作为下一个，你知道，
the, the ritual or the totem or the, you know, whatever is the next book on another metaphysical thing, or is it more, this was just kind of something you're chewing on and your career goes, you know, onto the next thing.
仪式、图腾，或者其他关于形而上学事物的下一本书，还是说这只是你正在咀嚼的东西，然后你的职业生涯会转向下一件事？
Do you view it as kind of a piece of something how i think i think it is i think it is the beginning of something um i suppose at the moment i'm doing some writing on my sub stack at the moment um just uh so i wrote um an essay recently called the demonic divine which so is is really thinking about a bit more about the curse in relation to numinous experience and how the curse is very much a person is in a kind of subjective prison, if you like. And ominous comes from the word omen right and in I don't know if you've read Rudolf Otto's the idea of the hominous yeah I'm familiar with the origin of numinous I was going to ask you if
你是否将其视为某种东西的一部分？我想，我想它是某种东西的开始。我想目前我正在我的Substack上写一些东西。我最近写了一篇名为《恶魔神圣》（The Demonic Divine）的文章，它更多地是在思考诅咒与神圣体验的关系，以及诅咒如何让一个人处于一种主观的监狱中。而“神圣”（Numinous）来自“预兆”（Omen），对吧？我不知道你是否读过鲁道夫·奥托（Rudolf Otto）的《神圣的观念》（The Idea of the Numinous）。是的，我熟悉“神圣”的起源。我正要问你，如果
we had longer why why you chose him yeah so yeah so basically he he thought well you've got omen ominous so he thought well not why not numen numous? So he came up with a numinous. And what's really interesting about that is that the numinous, it brings a person into a more objective realm rather than this kind of subjective prison. Okay, so I'm thinking about how the numinous can be a kind of cure in terms of helping somebody to think about or have a different experience with their own reality, if you like. So, yeah, so I suppose I'm thinking more about if, from that perspective, how I can think about in terms of spirituality in terms of healing um yeah here a spiritual so the numinous mystery the uncanny synchronicity all of these kind of things and how so building on what i'm saying in the book about
我们有更多时间的话，你为什么选择他。是的，所以基本上他想，好吧，你有“预兆”（Omen），所以他想为什么不是“神圣”（Numen/Numinous）？所以他提出了“神圣”这个词。有趣的是，神圣将一个人带入了一个更客观的领域，而不是这种主观的监狱。好的，所以我正在思考神圣如何成为一种治愈，帮助某人思考或对他们自己的现实有不同的体验。所以，是的，我想我正在从那个角度思考，我如何从灵性和治愈的角度来思考它。是的，神圣的神秘、不可思议、共时性，所有这些东西，以及如何在我书中所说的基础上建立，
magical curse consciousness less about less about the actual curse itself and more about um those areas instead yeah so yeah moving moving towards towards healing and um thinking about the role of art particularly and um and spiritual experience that's fascinating yeah i don't know i i would love to to have you on to talk about that when you get there. Okay, thank you very much, Joel. Cheers. Yeah, I'm kind of of the opinion that a lot of philosophy and psychology, if not all of it, and mythological anthropology maybe,
关于魔法诅咒意识，少谈论诅咒本身，多谈论那些领域。是的，所以朝着治愈的方向发展，思考艺术的作用，特别是精神体验。这太迷人了。是的，我不知道，当你写到那里时，我很乐意邀请你来谈谈。好的，非常感谢你，乔尔。干杯。是的，我的观点是，很多哲学和心理学，如果不是全部的话，还有神话人类学，
is just sort of fighting about object relations. That people are like, well, we have this inner world that doesn't match the outer world. Which one is valid? Well, the outer world feels real through spiritual experience. So the inner world is more valid than the outer or where does the outer world come from? Can they harmonize?
只是在争论客体关系。人们会说，好吧，我们有一个与外部世界不匹配的内心世界。哪一个是有效的？好吧，外部世界通过精神体验感觉是真实的。所以内心世界比外部世界更有效，或者外部世界从哪里来？它们能协调吗？
How much can they harmonize? Why are they different? You know, it's just... Yeah. Well, these are eternal conversations and it would be kind of hubristic, I think, to think that we can kind of solve those um because there are those tensions there aren't there um and it is very very difficult and and again a lot of
它们能协调到什么程度？为什么它们不同？你知道，这只是……是的。好吧，这些是永恒的对话，我认为如果我们认为我们可以解决这些问题会有点傲慢，因为那里存在着张力，不是吗？这非常非常困难，而且再次强调，很多
our work with clients is trying to help them to pass out in some way what it what are those things you know get a better understanding of the outer and the inner sure the subjective and the object objective as much as is possible yeah and holding the tension without knowing i mean my exactly even if i have a you know deterministic knowledge it isn't something that is relevant to the patient you know but it's their experience and their relationship with the that tension you know yeah 100 absolutely well i really appreciate you coming on. We'll definitely point to,
我们与客户的工作是试图帮助他们以某种方式理清这些事情，你知道，更好地理解外部和内部。当然，尽可能地理解主观和客观。是的，在不知道的情况下保持这种张力。我的意思是，即使我有一种决定论的知识，它对病人来说也不是相关的，你知道，但这是他们的体验以及他们与那种张力的关系。你知道，是的，100%绝对。好吧，我非常感谢你来参加。我们肯定会指向，
what do you want us to point to the book on Amazon and the website? Great. That's great. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. And then what is, what is the web address? I don't have that in front of me. I've got, well, actually. So the web address is alexmonktherapy.com. Okay. Well, thank you so much. And if there's ever anything I can do for you, let me know. We'd love to have you on again as new things come out.
你想让我们指向亚马逊上的书和网站吗？太棒了。那太好了。谢谢。是的，是的，是的。完美。那么网址是什么？我手头没有。实际上，网址是alexmonktherapy.com。好的，非常感谢。如果有什么我能为你做的，请告诉我。我们很乐意在新内容出来时再次邀请你。
Thanks very much, Joe. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢，乔。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。